the lord god called to the human and
said to him
where are you what a beautiful question
where are you
and this is kind of this existential
question for adam now
now the serpent was most cunning of all
the beasts of the field that the lord
god had made
and he said to the woman though god said
you shall not eat from any tree of the
garden
and the woman said to the serpent from
the fruit of the garden's trees we may
eat
but from the fruit of the tree in the
midst of the garden god has said you
shall not eat from it and you shall not
touch it
lest you die and the serpent said to the
woman you shall not be doomed to die for
god knows that on the day you eat of it
your eyes will be opened
and you will become as god's knowing
good
and evil and the woman saw that the tree
was good for eating and that it was lust
to the eyes and the tree was lovely to
look at
and she took of its fruit and ate and
she also gave to her man
and he ate and the eyes of the two were
opened and they knew they were
naked and they sow fig leaves and made
themselves
loin cloths so let's just begin
first and foremost with the narrative
that we know also well
god gave adam and eve a commandment
their prideful desire to become like
gods is it precisely what allows
them to be tempted by the serpent and
giving into this temptation
they break a commandment of god and thus
break their relationship
with the divine and as a consequence of
this
god of course escorts them out of the
garden
and in some ways we read this as a just
response
they had a commandment they broke the
commandment they broke their
relationship with the divine
and now of course they have to live
their life
quite differently now in this world and
they heard the sound of the lord god
walking about in the garden in the
evening breeze
and the human and his woman hid from the
lord god in the midst of the trees of
the garden
and the lord god called to the human and
said to him where are you what a
beautiful question where are you
i mean this is kind of this existential
question for adam now
just think about it he's hiding from his
creator the one to whom he was called to
be in relationship he's now hiding from
him
and he said i heard your sound in the
garden and i was afraid
for i was naked and i hid and he said
who told you that you were naked
from the tree i commanded you not to eat
have you eaten
in some ways we can look back to the
various traditions both rabbinic
and christian and they understand these
questions in a very precise way
and this is god calling adam and eve to
repentance
look the narrative here let's just boil
it down to some
something simple there are commandments
in this case there's one command
one is to keep it to stay in
relationship to the divine
follow the commandments if you don't
follow the commandments
simply turn back to god and say i'm
sorry god i did not follow the
commandments
and then of course you'll be asked to
follow the commandments
it's a really simple narrative that we
can see all throughout these biblical
texts
and in particular here and he said who
told you that you were naked
from the tree that i command you not to
eat you have eaten
and the human said here's his chance to
repent
the woman whom you gave by me she gave
me from the tree and i ate
now all of a sudden i think we can see
what's going on here if we're talking
about the intersection of the divine and
human relationship
combined with the human and human
relationship
then what we see here is is a rupture of
both simultaneously
adam who has his life who names himself
only after
uh this woman who's taken from him very
his very self
who gives him his sense of personhood
the sustainer beside him
notice what he's willing to do he cuts
her off and his language is perfect
the woman whom you gave to me in in a
double sense he's passing off this
responsibility
to his wife and now to god so we see a
simultaneous
uh disruption of the divine relationship
and the human relationship
here and the lord god said to the woman
what is this you have done
and the woman said the serpent beguiled
me and i ate
notice what she does here passes blame
off to the serpent
she doesn't even mention that she gave
the fruit to adam and he ate
she doesn't even mention this so let's
just go back a little bit
and ask a couple of questions
what is the state that adam and eve are
now in with regards
to their relationship to the divine they
stand in front of him naked and ashamed
whereas before they were naked and did
not know it
because they've had this double
knowledge they've transgressed and are
conscious of their transgression
now their state is one of shame and now
you can really start thinking about
justice and mercy
would not justice be god saying i told
you not to eat of the tree of knowledge
and good and evil
and yet you've done so and so now you
shall just
have the fruit of your transgression
here you shall now
live in this shame which you've brought
upon yourself
and so when we look here now that the
human has become like one of us knowing
good and evil
that let us not let them take from the
tree of life and live forever
god is not afraid of a rivalry of his
creation
he's not afraid that they've become gods
he set everything in place so that they
could become god-like
i mean really is a god who created mud
he's created
soil and he's turned them into gods is a
god
who has that sort of enormous power
really going to rival
these god-like creatures that he's
created from mud
rather it was a graciousness on the part
of the divine to say
i am going to create creatures who with
their will
can live and participate in the divine
life
and whereas at one point they had one
commandment to do so
well now okay we have the original
transgression
now they have 1613 commandments to do so
and those 1613 commandments should be
seen as a joy as another
a another opportunity to exist in that
divine and human relationship
so then what we see here then cutting
them off from the garden
of eden to put the cherubim at that tree
of life to cut them off from immortality
to become these god-like creatures
living in shame and perpetuity
rather than an act of justice it is an
act of mercy
rather than letting them by their own
free will create a hell
out of a paradise which he's given to
them he has cut them off from
that and is going to now allow them to
exist in relationship to the divine
in a different manner and the rest of
genesis
is going to be a teasing out and through
through the whole tanakh through the
whole hebrew bible
is going to be a question of what does
that new relationship
look like thank you for watching
we hope you're enjoying our highlight
series and invite you to explore
all of hillsdale college's online
courses they are free
and for everyone who loves to learn